hi und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr dabei seid ja es gab
neue russische Raketenangriffe heute
Nacht mehrere Städte in der Ukraine
wurden angegriffen dabei sind sechs
Menschen gestorben und mehr als 20
wurden verletzt Präsident selenski
spricht von russischen Killern und
dieser Angriffe Folgen auf eine ganze
Reihe von Angriffen innerhalb der
letzten Woche die sich auch über das
ganze Land verteilen immer wieder werden
Zivilisten ziel dieser Angriffe und
gleichzeitig ist auch die ukrainische
Offensive im Gange wir haben hier in den
letzten Monaten ja ganz viel darüber
diskutiert ob wie wo und wann sie
startet die ukrainische Führung
vermeldet Erfolge und spricht von sieben
befreiten Ortschaften die russische
Führung wiederum spricht von hohen
ukrainischen Verlusten wir wollen heute
darüber sprechen wie diese Offensive
läuft wo die ukrainischen Truppen
vorankommen und wie hat die Gegenwehr
ist und wir wollen uns auch die Frage
stellen die hier schon hinter mir steht
nämlich bricht die russische Front und
wie immer tue ich das nicht alleine
sondern ich habe zwei gesprächsgäste ich
spreche zum einen mit Oberst Markus
Reisner vom österreichischen Bundesheer
und mit meiner Kolleginnen und ZDF
Reporterin Alissa jung die für uns in
saporija ist und wie immer diskutiere
ich auch mit euch habt ihr da draußen
Fragen oder Meinungen zum Thema die ihr
mit uns in dieser Sendung teilen wollt
dann schreibt sie gerne in den
youtube-chat oder per Mail an die
Mail-Adresse die ihr gerade eingeblendet
seht so und bevor wir ins diskutieren
kommen bevor ich mit oberstreisner ins
Gespräch zum Status Quo dieser
ukrainischen Offensive komme hier eine
kurze Vorstellung meines ersten
Gesprächs
militäranalytiker Historiker und aktiver
Soldat Oberst Markus Reißner analysiert
den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine seit dessen beginnen Reißner
leitet seit September 2022 die
Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung an
der Theresianischen Militärakademie in
Wien und ist Kommandant des
österreichischen gardebataillos zu
sofort von 2004 bis 2013 war reißna Teil
einer Spezialeinheit des
österreichischen Bundesheers in dieser
Zeit nahm er an verschiedenen
Auslandseinsätzen Teil etwa in Mali der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik Bosnien
und Herzegowina Kosovo Schatz und
Afghanistan
ja und da ist er mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet herzlich willkommen Herr
Reissner
herzlichen Dank
hinter ihnen ist schon eine Karte
aufgebaut lassen Sie uns doch mal
gemeinsam einen Blick auf diese Karte
werfen an welchen Orten macht sich die
ukrainische Offensive die jetzt lange
erwartet und besprochen wurde den gerade
bemerkbar
ja versuchen wir ganz kurz zusammen zu
fassen was in den letzten knapp zehn
Tagen passiert ist die mit der großer
Wartung hinterlegte Offensive hat
begonnen und die Offensive stellt sich
im Moment wie folgt da man kann erkennen
dass es drei Stoßrichtungen gibt es
quasi die von der Seiten der Ukraine
versucht wird auch tatsächlich
voranzutreiben wenn uns den Raum grob
ansehen dann sehen wir das hier zwischen
melittopol und mariopol sich ein
günstiger Raum darstellt für eine
möglichen Stoß bis zu mal so viel mehr
der dann die russischen Kräfte teilen
würde was wir kennen zurzeit ist das ein
Beginn der Angriffe es tatsächlich die
Russen geschafft haben signifikant auch
einen Abwehr Erfolg zum Teil in der
gefechtsverposten Linie zu ziehen aber
Seite so ca 48 Stunden gelingt es den
Ukraine langsam Fuß zu fassen und Raum
zu gewinnen und unter anderem hier im
Zentralraum wo es gelungen ist insgesamt
sieben Ortschaften zu nehmen nicht so
günstig stellt sich die Lage da zurzeit
im Park Mut wo man ebenfalls in den
Gegenangriffe gegangen ist und im
eigentlichen schwergewichtsgebiet
nördlich von militopol wo vor kurzem
auch diese musste an amerikanischen
Bradley kampfschützenpanzern und
deutschen leopardkampfpanzern erlitten
worden sind
ja sie sprechen von drei Stoßrichtungen
können Sie da schon was sagen mit
welchen Verbänden wird dort vorgegangen
und kann man da schon eine Strategie
ablesen
ja wenn wir uns kurz zurück erinnern
dann wissen wir dass er die Brigaden die
die Ukraine bereitgestellt hat
einerseits ausgestattet worden sind vom
westlichen Gerät aber anderer Ukraine
selbst aufgebracht worden sind da gibt
es insgesamt 12 9 ausgestattet mit
westlichen Gerät und drei originäre
ukrainische Brigaden dazu kommen jene
Verbände die sich an der Front befinden
von den Bildern die wir jetzt kennen und
das wissen wir vor allem aufgrund des
eingesetzten Geräts wie z.B diese
Leopard Bradley oder auch diese
französischen amix-szene
aufklärungspanzer wissen wir dass
zumindest vier Brigaden sich bereits im
Einsatz befinden das heißt ein Drittel
der Kräfte während zwei Drittel immer
noch im Bereitstellung warten und
vermutlich auf die das Ergebnis
warten im Wesentlichen und dann also
dort eingesetzt werden
ich habe gerade schon mal einen Blick in
den Chat geworfen und ist türmen sich
schon die Fragen an sie herreisen wir
werden gleich gemeinsam noch mal über
ihre Einschätzung zu den Erfolgschancen
dieser Offensive sprechen bis gleich
in der Nähe dieser umkämpften Gebiete in
diesen drei Stoßrichtungen die wir
gerade mit Herrn Reißner betrachten
betrachtet haben befindet sich aktuell
meine Kollegin Alisa jung nämlich in
saporisha das seht ihr hier einmal auf
der Karte eingezeichnet die Punkte die
ihr da gerade seht das sind diese
befreiten Ortschaften von der die
Ukraine jetzt spricht und jetzt schalten
wir mal rüber zu Alisa was sie dort
erlebt hallo schön dass du und bei uns
bist
hallo Viktoria
Alissa du bist vor Ort kannst du und
sagen warum es aktuell so schwer ist
über diese Offensive zu berichten
ich bin in saporisha das sind rund 100
km noch bis zur Frontlinie im Süden wo
aktuell die Gefechte stattfinden massiv
Gefechte stattfinden und natürlich ist
das jetzt keine Zone in der aktuell
Journalisten Journalistin zugelassen
sind man muss sich das so vorstellen
grundsätzlich ganz allgemein gilt hier
in der Ukraine schon eine Regel seit
geraumer Zeit die besagt es gibt eine
grüne Zone eine gelbe Zone und eine rote
Zone die grüne klar da kann man sich
frei bewegen die gelbe da nur unter
Aufsicht und in der roten da auf gar
keinen Fall und natürlich an der
Frontlinie so auch gar nicht jetzt gibt
es ihr habt das angesprochen schon
natürlich die Berichte über die ersten
befreiten kleineren Ortschaften das
wären jetzt natürlich Gebiete wo wir als
Presse uns auch gerne selbst ein Bild
vor Ort von der Situation von der Lage
machen würden die wir dort vorfinden
aber auch stand jetzt ist dort kein
Zugang denn das wäre einfach zu
gefährlich das ist natürlich ein ganz
wichtiger Grund weil wenn dann könnte
man da ja nur Begleitung mit Begleitung
auch rein und man muss sich das so
vorstellen dass da ja nicht erst seit
gestern sondern sehr sehr lange schon
intensiv gekämpft wird das sind also
Gebiete die im Zweifel vermiet sind das
sind Gebiete wo nicht ganz klar ist ob
da nicht auch weiter von den Gefechten
also auch noch Einschläge hinkommen
können da muss also ein gewisser Abstand
zur Frontlinie dann überhaupt erstmal
hergestellt werden dass wir als Presse
dort überhaupt erst in Begleitung und
das ist ja auch ein wichtiger Punkt
überhaupt erst hin könnten deswegen ist
das nicht so einfach darüber zu
berichten aktuell über jetzt konkret die
Frontlinie da ist es gut dass ihr euch
jetzt natürlich Herrn Reißner eingeladen
habt um über die Militär Taktik zu
sprechen über die nämlich hier von
ukrainischer Seite natürlich auch nichts
verraten wird dann möchte man hier
einfach nichts preisgeben und das wäre
auch noch ein letzter Punkt den ich da
gerne anbringen möchte denn auch wenn
wir denn dann drehen können geht es
natürlich auch darum keine ukrainischen
Stellungen zu verraten oder irgendetwas
was der russischen Seite nützt das wäre
natürlich hier für die ukrainische Seite
im Krieg sehr sehr schwierig
ja du sagst gerade alles was in Richtung
Militär Taktik Strategie der Ukraine
geht bleibt natürlich geheim du kannst
ja aber vor Ort immer wieder mit den
Menschen sprechen die unmittelbar von
diesem Krieg betroffen sind was ist denn
deine Einschätzung wie schätzen die
Ukraine und Ukraine sind die
Erfolgschancen dieser Offensive ein
wir sind jetzt seit zwei Tagen hier in
der Stadt unterwegs und mit vielen
Menschen sprechen können auch auf der
Straße einfach Menschen angesprochen und
haben gesagt wie seht ihr das glaubt ihr
das wird jetzt schnell gehen glaubt ihr
das braucht noch sehr lange Zeit was ist
eure Einschätzung und was da ein ganz
wichtiger und interessanter Punkt war
dem man glaube ich nicht vergessen darf
hier von den Menschen in saporiza und
das sind natürlich auch viele Frauen die
Männer die Väter die Söhne das sind die
die gerade aktuell an der Front kämpfen
das heißt also für die ist das natürlich
hier eine ganz ganz ganz persönliche
Sache und da geht es auch nicht nur
darum welche Erfolge man da jetzt im
Süden an der Frontlinie erzählt im
Südosten sondern auch natürlich das
sagte uns hier eine Abgeordnete das City
councils also hier in der Stadt die
sagte da geht's ja auch darum dass nicht
so viele Menschen dabei sterben weil das
sind ja ihre Leute hier und das sind
ihre Angehörigen ihre Freunde ihre
Liebsten und insofern wünscht man sich
natürlich enorme Erfolge aber das
natürlich auch nur unter Vorsicht man
wir haben auch skeptische Töne gehört wo
natürlich ist Befürchtungen gibt das
jetzt durch die großen Überschwemmungen
die es nach dem staudammbruch unten bei
trasson gab auch die russischen Truppen
nach oben gewandert sein könnten also
dort unterstützen könnten die Menschen
sind hier auch besorgt dass auch und wir
waren heute das war auch spannend bei
einer Initiative von Frauen das sind
einige Frauen wo eben die Männer kämpfen
im Krieg das sind Frauen die also Netze
Tarnnetze für die Männer an der Front
knüpfen und die waren auch sehr
angespannt natürlich haben
regelmäßig Kontakt dann doch über
Telefon auch zu ihren Männern an der
Front und hier schaut man natürlich noch
mal unter einem ganz anderen Aspekt auf
diese Kriegssituation und auch über den
Erfolg oder Misserfolg den die Ukraine
da jetzt macht in den nächsten Wochen
ja bedrückender menschlicher Einblick
den du dafür uns hast ich habe auch
gleich noch eine Frage aus der Community
an Dich hier fragt jemand wie geht es
denn dem AKW nach der dammsprengung gibt
es da neue Entwicklung
also das Atomkraftwerk hier von
saporisha das wurde besucht heute von
dem Leiter der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossy vor seinem
Besuch hat er ein Statement abgegeben in
Kiew hat sich dabei auch besorgt darüber
geäußert deswegen ist er natürlich
hierher gereist um sich selbst ein Bild
von der Lage zu machen denn es gibt dort
einfach die Situation dass durch den
staudammbruch auch das Reservoir der
Pegel im Reservoir was für die Kühlung
der Reaktoren das abgeschalteten AKWs
also das im gesamten genutzt wird dass
dort der Pegel abgesagt ist und da
möchte sich jetzt natürlich der Leiter
selbst ein Bild vor Ort machen es gibt
zwar alternative Kühlsysteme um die
Frage zu beantworten heute hat der
Leiter grossi noch mal gesagt für
mehrere Wochen wenn nicht Monate sei
vorgesorgt aber nichtsdestotrotz sein
dass eine besorgniserregende Situation
nicht eine unmittelbare Gefahr aber eine
mittelfristige die er jetzt selber mit
seinem Team über mehrere Tage das Team
das bleibt nämlich evaluieren möchte
ja meine Kollegin Alicia jung mit den
Eindrücken außer vielen dank dir und
alles Gute in Ukraine
und wir sprechen jetzt über die
Erfolgschancen dieser ukrainischen
Offensive und dazu spreche ich noch mal
mit Obers Markus Reißner vom
österreichischen Bundesheer der uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist wenn ihr da
draußen Fragen an Herrn reißen habt dann
schickt sie uns gerne jetzt in den
youtube-chat oder per Mail an die
eingeblendete Adresse hallo noch mal
heraus
wie schätzen sie denn aktuell die
Erfolgschancen dieser Offensive ein
ja bevor ich damit beginnen möchte ich
mich ganz kurz davor rederin anschließen
und möchte so betonen all die Dinge die
ich jetzt sehr technisch und militärisch
Ausdrücke darf man nicht vergessen sind
natürlich mit den enormen Leid verbunden
und während wir hier reden vor allem
also auf beiden Seiten hunderte Soldaten
und werden getötet und tausende werden
verwundet das dürfen wir also bitte hier
nicht vergessen wenn wir uns die
Erfolgschancen da ob Offensive vor Augen
führen da muss man also klar sagen dass
der Krieg in verschiedenen Domänen
geführt wird wir haben natürlich jetzt
immer sehr das Land Domain im Blick also
das was sie sehen im Fernsehen die
Panzer reformieren möglicherweise auch
das luftdomain Hubschrauber kam
Hubschrauber und so weiter und so fort
und man muss klar sagen dass es so für
beide Konfliktparteien eines Vor und
Nachteile in den unterschiedlichen
Domänen gibt die Herausforderung für die
Ukraine ist dass sie also kaum
Luftstreitkräfte verfügbar hat es gibt
zwar immer wieder spektakuläre Angriffe
auch in der Tiefe der von der großen
besetzten Gebiete auf z.B gefechtstände
oder auch Logistik Punkte aber es gibt
keine funktionierende unmittelbare Luft
da Unterstützung oder auch keine
funktionierende unmittelbare
entsprechend Unterstützung gegen
feierliche Kampfhubschraubern und
ähnliches und das macht es so schwierig
und wir haben gesehen also beim ersten
Angriff wo diese hohen Verluste erlitten
worden sind auch internationale
militärblocker sprechen von insgesamt 16
zerstörten amerikanischen
kampfschützenpanzern und manche sagen
vier bis sieben Jahre zerstörten
Leopards das ist auch durch Bilder
dokumentiert da kann man also sehr gut
erkennen das ist sehr schwierig ist
quasi für die Ukraine hier Raum zu
gewinnen wir haben also jetzt zur Zeit
tatsächlich ja gewisse Gelände Gewinne
aber jetzt in Relation zu der Distanz
die also noch vor Ihnen liegt sieht man
natürlich dass er hier diese Ortschaften
im Besitz genommen sind ein
signifikantes Zeichen sind aber wenn ich
in dieser Vorstoß nur wenige Kilometer
bis jetzt betragen hat also fünf sechs
km hat man hier bereits befreit es
stehen aber noch ca 100 km vor den
ukrainischen Truppen bis zu mal so viel
mehr das ist das operative Ziel um
strategisch dann diese Teilung der
Russen tatsächlich zu erreichen man muss
jetzt abwarten es ist so dass der
Angreifer immer den Nachteil hat wenn
auf einen Verteidiger trifft der
vorbereitet ist dass der Verteidiger ihm
auch seine Kampfweise aufzwingen kann
eben durch diese z.B angelegten
Verteidigung Stellungen und da ist es
auch zu erwarten dass der Angreifer
Verluste hat so wie wir das gesehen
haben das Interessante ist dass die
Verluste sehr früh begonnen haben in
diesem gefechtsverposten dienen und das
einige Fähigkeiten der russischen Seite
wie zum Beispiel Einsatz von
Kampfhubschraubern kann Flugzeugen aber
auch das elektromagnetische Feld dass
man eigentlich so nicht erwartet hat
dann doch signifikant dazu beigetragen
die haben gerade schon angesprochen
Stichwort russische Gegenwehr wie ist
die denn ihre Einschätzung nach aktuell
aufgestellt
ja die Russen hatten jetzt dann mehrere
Monate knapp sechs Monate Zeit um sich
hier einzurichten es ist eine
Kombination zwischen dass sie einerseits
pioniert Kräften die also hier
qualifikationsanlagen angelegt haben in
einem sehr ausgeglichen System
untereinander gestapelt auch mehreren
tiefen und in mehreren Linien angelegt
wir haben es einerseits eine Kombination
aus Minenfeldern das Panzergräben aus
diesen drachenzähnen von denen man schon
gesprochen hat und so weiter und so fort
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so
dass die Russen offensichtlich eine
bewegliche Verteidigung durchführen das
heißt sie haben also kleine Elemente
dieses Jahr rasch quasi von A nach B
sind können die z.B mit
panzerverlängerung von den Ukraine große
Probleme bereiten und Sie haben
natürlich die Komponente auch der
Luftwaffe die immer wieder gezielt zum
Einsatz kommt Luftwaffe bedeutet das
russische sich z.B Einsatz von
Kampfhubschraubern die sondern Distanz
von bis zu 8 km entsprechend sehr
wirksame Panzer für Raketen abfahren
können und das bereitet diese Probleme
die sich dann in diesen Bildern
ausgedrückt haben die wenn der letzten
Tagen gesehen haben da gehe ich einmal
gleich direkt rein diese
verteidigungswelle
diese Anlagen die sie besprochen haben
das hat mein Kollege Carsten heckes mal
für uns zusammengefasst wie die
eigentlich aussehen
Bilder der ukrainischen Armee sie sollen
die Befreiung der Ortschaft macarivka in
der Region Donezk zeigen Kios Offensive
läuft über ihren Erfolg entscheidet auch
die russische Gegenwehr eine Analyse des
us-verteidigungsexperten Brady afric
zeigt von Russland errichtete
Verteidigungsanlagen in den vergangenen
Monaten wurden sie hauptsächlich an der
Front und umstützpunkte herumgebaut aber
auch im nördlichen Teil der
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Halbinsel Krim sind auf
Satellitenaufnahmen einige Anlagen zu
sehen die Systeme bestehen dabei aus
mehreren Befestigungen und Hindernissen
das folgende Beispiel zeigt eine Anlage
zwischen saporishia und militopol
zu den russischen Verteidigungsanlage
gehören Tiefe geräben und erdwelle vor
allem gegen Panzer auf frisch
gepflückten erwarten Experten außerdem
Landminen davor und dahinter kommt
vorgefertigte Verteidigungslinien
sogenannte Drachenzähne das sind oftmals
höckerförmige sperren aus Beton die
Panzer stoppen sollen
ja Gräben erdwelle
Drachenzähne das klingt jetzt erstmal
sehr beeindruckend wir hatten auch
letztens den Militärexperten Markus Kolb
bei uns der sagte allerdings diese
Anlagen diese russischen Design gar
nicht so undurchdringbar man würde
nämlich auf der Karte des Verteidigungs
Experten Brady afric auch sehen dass die
gar nicht durchgängig sind und das hat
er ganz klar als Schwäche identifiziert
ich ähm Werft da mal kurz einen Blick
auf die Karte auf meinem Laptop äh damit
ihr das da draußen vielleicht ein
bisschen nachvollziehen können wovon wir
sprechen also alles was hier rot ist das
sind diese verteidigungswelle die wir
gerade gesehen haben und ihr seht auf
der Karte da sind zwar durchgängige
Reihen zu erkennen die sind aber immer
wieder gespickt mit Lücken und das hatte
damals der Herr Kolb angemerkt dass das
eigentlich schon zeigt dass diese
russische Abwehr diese russische
Verteidigung in seinen Augen recht
schwach ist
würden sie diese Einschätzung teilen
herausreißen
nun einer der wichtigsten Faktoren in
der Einsatzführung und auch in der
Taktik ist natürlich das Gelände das
heißt das Gelände stellt sich in der
Struktur unterschiedlich da wenn wir auf
die Karte blicken so haben wir den
scheinbaren Eindruck dass es hier sehr
flach ist was ich in der Wüste da stimmt
natürlich nicht das ist eine
Aneinanderreihung von unterschiedlichen
geländesstrukturen wir haben einen Wald
wir haben zum Beispiel einen Fluss seine
Kanal eine Höhe und eine tiefe wir haben
einen felsigen Bereich wir haben zum
Beispiel einen sehr abbaugängigen
Bereich und all diese Dinge und das hat
natürlich einen Einfluss auf die Art und
Weise wie pionierkräfte sperren anlegen
das heißt sie haben also im flachen
Gelände vergleichbares quasi mit der
bäuerlichen Landschaft mit Eckern haben
sie natürlich die Möglichkeit einen
Panzergraben zu ziehen oder Minenfeld zu
legen wenn also dann dieser Panzergraben
in einen künstlichen Kanal zu
Bewässerung übergeht müssen Sie nicht
extra einen Kanal entsprechend graben
sondern sie haben diesen Wasserkanal
wenn das ganze noch einen Fluss
anschließt haben sie das natürliche
Hindernis des Flusses das ja dann
passiert werden muss von den angreifen
auf einer Höhe bietet sich an zum
Beispiel eine Stellung zu beziehen für
eine panzerverlängerung für die voller
Sperre in der Tiefe also auf diesen
vorgenannten ackerfeldern zum Beispiel
überwacht das heißt man darf sich hier
nicht täuschen lassen von der möglichen
nicht durch die Linien sondern diese
Linien sind natürlich abhängig vom
Gelände gezogen und die russische Seite
hat natürlich versucht gerade dort wo
das Gelände sich günstig darstellt für
eine mechanisierten Angriff das ist im
sehr offenen Gelände jene sperren zuerst
anzulegen und dann natürlich da wo es
ist nicht mehr von der Zeit der gegangen
ist andere Bereiche auszusparen im
Wesentlichen ja das heißt ich würde sehr
vorsichtig sein mit dieser Aussage wobei
man natürlich klar sagen muss dass die
Kriegsgeschichte voller Beispiele ist wo
der hatte gewinnen den Gegner nicht
aufgehalten haben
und zu diesem Thema Komplex haben wir
auch gleich eine Frage aus der Community
an sie da fragt Eduard kommt auf YouTube
wo würden sie einen Durchbruch bzw
angriffsschwerpunkte der Ukraine
vermuten bisher sieht man ja an mehreren
Stellen Angriffe und Geländegewinne aber
ohne volle Stärke
genau was wir erkennen können sind das
also circa vier Brigaden dieser Brigaden
der Offensive im Einzel sind wir sehen
aber auch das unmittelbar vorher an der
Front eingesetzte Brigaden sich im
Angriff befinden was man natürlich sagen
kann ist dass aufgrund des eingesetzten
Gerätes man schon eine gewisse
schwergewichtsbildung erkennen kann und
natürlich das beste Gerät sollte dann im
Schwergewicht eingesetzt werden und das
war der Einsatz von diesen
leopardkampfpanzern aber auch von diesen
prädikampf Schützenpanzern der Breite
kampfschützenpanzer ist eigentlich das
beste gelieferte Gerät was das betrifft
da von Seiten des Westens besser als der
Marder zum Beispiel und auf jeden Fall
besser als diese minengeschützen
Fahrzeuge die wir auch schon im Einsatz
gesehen haben das heißt aufgrund dieses
Geräts aber auch aufgrund von
Spezialgerät und das ist auch wichtig
denn um diese Sperren zu überwinden
braucht man zum Beispiel für einen
Minenfeld braucht man eine
minenrollenpanzer mit Rollen oder mit
drei Schlägeln man braucht man für den
Panzergraben einen brückenlegepanzer als
Beispiel und hierbei gesehen dass
signifikant diese minenrollen Banz
eingesetzt worden sind bei diesen
Leopard und der Bradley Einheiten und
das war zum Beispiel die 47
konkrete sich eine Zahl zu nennen die im
Einsatz war daraus würde sich schließen
lassen dass der hauptansatz zur Zeit
momentan in Richtung dogmark das ist
nördlich vom minitopol erzielt und das
Gelände ist auch dort relativ offen da
würde sich das auch anbieten aber das
heißt natürlich nicht dass die Ukraine
hier in diesem Plan festhalten müssen es
kann also sein dass man im Zentralraum
also Ostdeutschland durchaus Ergebnisse
erzielt wie man das jetzt sieht mit
diesen Einnahmen von diesen sieben
Dörfern und dass man die zwei Drittel
die man noch in Reserve hat dann
umgruppiert und dann dort ansetzen lässt
weil dort das Gelände vielleicht
günstiger ist oder dort sich die
russische schwächer erweisen dass sie
hängt natürlich jetzt ab von der
operativen Einsatzführung der Befehl ist
aber auch ukrainischer Seite
dieser Krieg ist ja auch gekennzeichnet
von hohen Verlusten auf beiden Seiten
und wenn man sich jetzt diese massiven
verteidigungswelle an guckt dann stellt
sich ja automatisch die Frage hat die
russische Armee eigentlich genug sollten
um all diese Verteidigungsanlagen zu
bewachen
und da ist es Dilemma folgendes und da
zitiere ich eine Aussage von dem
kommentierenden General der
US-Streitkräfte in Europa Generali der
vor kurzem gesagt hat dass die Russen
circa 350 bis 400.000 Mann im Einsatz
haben also das Doppelte von dem mit dem
sie einmarschiert sind es drängt sich
sogar der Verdacht auf dass die Kämpfe
im Park Mut vor allem dazu gedient haben
die Ukraine hier in diesen Raum
entsprechend zu beschäftigen um genug
Zeit für die Vorbereitungen zu treffen
auf die erwartende Offensive und diese
Stellungen die sich angelegt sind haben
durch den Vorteil dass es möglich machen
geringere Kräfte aufgrund der
stellungsausbau entsprechend einsetzen
zu können und das sehen wir auch gerade
die Russen haben also in der stationären
Einsatzführung Vorteile ob es die
Einsatz der eigenen Artillerie ist der
Bereich der Elektro des elektronischen
Kampfes z.B oder auch die Luft nach
Unterstützung diese offensichtlich in
den leichter macht aus den Stellungen
heraus diesen Abwehrkampf zu führen und
das hat vor allem man beginnt zu diesem
Verlusten auf ukrainischer Seite geführt
das muss jetzt nicht heißen dass diese
Stellungen die Ukraine aufhalten können
denn es geht ja nicht darum diese
Stellungen und breiter vor uns zu
durchbrechen sondern man muss dann
einigen günstigen Stellen in einen
entsprechenden Durchbruch erzielen und
der Rest der Stellungen hat sich dann
eigentlich aus unnötig erwiesen weil man
durch diese durchbruchstelle Reise
schnell vorstoßen kann
ja und da schließt sich gerade auch noch
eine Frage aus der Community an von
Christoph der fragt welche Waffen bzw
Fähigkeiten fehlen den Ukrainern die
jetzt schleunigst geliefert werden
müssen um wie sie gerade sagen so ein
Durchbruch an einer oder an einigen
Stellen leisten zu können
ja was ich natürlich hier ganz klar
aufdringt im Vergleich der Kräfte auf
beiden Seiten ist der Umstand dass die
Ukraine offensichtlich der
Herausforderung hat dass sie nur
geringverfügbare Luftstreitkräfte hat es
gibt also zwar einige Luftfahrzeuge wie
z.B diese su24m die sehr gezielt durch
den Einsatz von britischen Storm auch in
der Tiefe wirken können aber wir haben
keine unmittelbar mitten in der Luft und
Unterstützung also Kampfflugzeuge die
für den unmittelbaren Kampf quasi vor
Ort vorgesehen sind zu Unterstützung zum
Beispiel dieser minenräume in Elemente
oder Kampfhubschrauber zum Beispiel ja
beide dienen auch dazu die gegnerischen
Kampfhubschrauber und kam Flugzeuge auf
Distanz auf Abstand zu halten das war ja
das was am Beginner nicht gelungen ist
das nächste sind natürlich auch Flieger
Systeme die mitfahren müssen um zu
verhindern dass russische
Kampfhubschrauber aber sie diese Erfolge
noch einmal erziehen können und das
sieht man natürlich diese Defizite die
sich hier ergeben natürlich ja kann man
sagen man kann also das entsprechend
durch einen sehr straff geführten Ansatz
und schmale und tiefer wegmachen aber
wenn man jetzt in der Kriegsgeschichte
ein paar Beispiele sich vor Augen führt
und eines glaube ich kann nicht jeder
sofort und nachvollziehbar einordnen das
ist die alliierte Landung in der
Normandie 1944 und da weiß man das in
den Wochen und Monaten davor gerade der
Einsatz der britischen amerikanischen
Luftwaffe dazu geführt hat dass die
deutschen Stellungen entsprechend
vorbereitet wurden dass die
logistiknotenpunkte angegriffen worden
sind in der Tiefe und da schlussendlich
am tag der Landung ist verhindert worden
ist dass die deutschen Panzer Divisionen
die Küste gekommen sind und diese
Komponente ist hier wesentlich geringer
ausgeprägt und wie sie also schon auch
gesehen haben in englischsprachigen
Medien wird auch darauf hingewiesen dass
die F16 jetzt natürlich eine sehr
günstige Rolle gespielt haben
lassen wir uns vom Thema Luftwaffe noch
mal auf Panzer kommen sie haben das ganz
am Anfang schon mal angesprochen es
wurden ja Leopard und Bradley Panzer vor
ein paar Tagen von den Russen quasi
erbeutelt aus Moskau gab es da heute
diese Bilder die wir ja auch gleich
sehen werden wo die Aufnahmen entstanden
sind ist allerdings unklar jetzt fragt
man sich natürlich wie schwer wie denn
die Verluste dieser Panzer auf der
ukrainischen Seite
man kann die Bilder sehr klar einordnen
indem man also quasi die tatsächlichen
Aufnahmen vergleicht mit dem Gelände und
damit weiß man auch wo das passiert ist
nördlich von der dogmark bei
malerdruckmatschka dort war dieser
zweimalige Versuch des Vorstoßes wo also
diese Verluste litten worden sind viel
schwerer als der Verlust der
leopardkampfbahns und der Kampf war der
kampfschützenpanzer vom Typ Bradley
wirkt natürlich der Verlust quasi dieses
Spezial minenräumgerät das was auch hier
verloren worden ist zum Beispiel von den
sechs gelieferten Stückzahlen von einem
speziell mining angeht das Finnland
wurden bereits drei möglicherweise vier
sogar zerstört aber das ist natürlich
die Herausforderung dass gerade diese
Spezialgerät benötigt wird und diese
Stellungen entsprechend zu überwinden
und das macht natürlich auch schwierig
wenn wir die Verluste in eine gesamt
Relation setzen also auch jetzt zum
Beispiel diese vier Brigaden und die
acht Brigaden die also noch Interesse
sind das sind die Verluste noch immer
relativ gering sie sind nur überraschend
hoch bereits für den Beginn der
Offensive nämlich in der sogenannten
gefechtsverposten Dinge das heißt noch
vorteiligen Hauptverteidigungslinie und
das ist das überraschende mit dem die
griechische Seite so sicherlich nicht
gerechnet hat
jetzt gab es in der Vergangenheit auch
schon den Fall dass Ukraine auch im
Besitz von russischen Panzern gekommen
sind die sie auch für sich einsetzen
konnten wie ist denn das jetzt mit den
Russen und den Leopard und Bradley
Gefährten können die diese auch einfach
so einsetzen oder welchen Nutzen haben
die von diesen Geräten
das hat natürlich auch vor allem einen
Nutzen im sogenannten Informationsraum
es geht hier in diesem Krieg vor allem
um den Informationsraum und das
beeinflussen des anderen der Zielgruppe
des anderen der eigenen Bevölkerung und
das sind die Bilder natürlich von diesen
zerstörten leoparda Kampfpanzern ganz
wichtig für dieses russische narrativ
auch diesen Großen Vaterländischen Krieg
2.0 zu führen in den russischen sozialen
Netzwerken sieht man Bilder auf der
einen Seite einen zerstörten deutschen
tigerpanzer aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
auf der anderen Seite quasi diesen
zerstörten Leopard-Panzer das ist
eigentlich das große bedeutungsvolle das
Fahrzeug selber ist natürlich
interessant für die russische Seite was
die Auswertung der Technik betrifft hier
kann man auch möglicherweise damit
rechnen dass er Komponenten davon
weitergegeben werden zum Beispiel im
Kino und sonst so aber dann nutzen
selber für die Armee der ist ja gering
und zwar alleine aufgrund der Tatsache
dass man nicht die entsprechende
Munition verfügbar hat möglicherweise
die Munition die noch am Fahrzeug war
aber nicht um das Fahrzeug logistisch
über lange sich betreiben zu können
deswegen die Ersatzteile es werden alle
diese Komponenten die notwendig sind
dann wird vielleicht der Bilder schaffen
wo man diesen Kampf Mann so sieht aber
tatsächlich ist er für die
Einsatzführung nicht geeignet
jetzt hat Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius ja ab Juni noch mal von 100
Panzern gesprochen die in die Ukraine
sollen wäre das denn ein privater Ersatz
würden jetzt schneller kommen für diese
Leoparden die sich die Russen zu eigen
gemacht haben
natürlich ist die Lieferung von weiteren
Panzer eine wesentliche Unterstützung
für die ukrainische Seite die
Problematik ergibt sich nicht nur aus
der Quantität sondern auch aus der
Qualität die ihr so von Ihnen genannten
Leopard 1 Kampfpanzer sind auf dem
technischen Stand wie zum Beispiel ein
russischer t-62 also die Optiken haben
ungefähr dieselbe Wirkung zum Teil auch
schlechter das heißt es gibt also hier
keinen wirklich wesentlichen Vorteil im
Vergleich zu den Leopard 2 oder gar
diesen Leopard 2 A6 dem wäre sie hier
gesehen haben aber die Menge alleine
macht schon einen Unterschied wir sehen
das auch auf russischer Seite die Russen
verwendet den 50er und 60er Jahren zum
Teil der Sturmgeschütze dazu
Unterstützung weil sie ihres System aber
hier ist es natürlich auch die Masse
Unterschied macht der also dann aufgrund
dieser langen Front natürlich eingesetzt
werden kann sie dürfen nicht vergessen
wir reden hier von einer Frau die 1200
km lang ist das ist wie wenn sie in
Berlin ins Auto steigen bis nach London
fahren und hier wird es oft vergessen
durch den Blick auf die Karte wir
glauben das ist relativ eng und begrenzt
in Wirklichkeit sind das sehr sehr große
Ausdehnungen und da verschwinden dann
120 gleich einmal im Gelände und das
sozusagen
sie sagen ja auch die aktuellen Kämpfe
dieser Offensive das sind Kämpfe die
sind sehr verlustreich für die Ukraine
können Sie mir und den Zuschauern und
Zuschauen einmal erklären wie sie zu
dieser Einschätzung kommen weil es gibt
ja aus diesem Krieg immer nur relativ
wenige Information es ist schwer die zu
verifizieren wir finden uns ja auch wie
sie gerade gesagt haben in einer Art
Informationskrieg
genau das ist der wesentliche Punkt und
hier muss man ganz klar sagen dass die
Bilder die wir jetzt bekommen natürlich
vor allem von der russischen Seite
geliefert werden denn die Russen
versuchen natürlich diese Erfolge
auszuschlachten für die eigene
Propaganda und auch quasi im Prinzip zur
Einschüchterung der Soldaten vor Ort wir
haben sehr sehr wenige Bilder von
ukrainischer Seite klar es gilt also
hier eine absolute Schweigepflicht um
also nicht der eigene Operationsführung
zu verraten aber die Bilder die man
natürlich von russischer Seite sehen
zeigen dass das Fahrzeuge ausgebrannt
sind das ist Minen Treffer gab und so
weiter und so fort das ist Treffer
gehabt sucht den Einsatz aussehen kann
Hubschrauber oder auch Panzer bei
Lenkwaffen und da muss man leider davon
ausgehen dass es auch nicht wenige
Soldaten gefallen sind es gibt auch
erste Videos auf russische Seite die
gefallene ukrainische Soldaten zeigen es
gibt aber auch Videos von der
ukrainischen Seite die Gefangene
russische Soldaten zeigen die sehen sie
natürlich nicht in den russischen
sozialen Netzwerk ist ganz klar aber das
Problem ist Offensive ist wenn Sie hier
mit geballter Bucht der Streitkräfte
aufeinander fallen dann ist es leider
damit verbunden und hier schließt sich
der Geist zu dem Beginn gesagt hat dass
er hier auch sehr viele Leute sterben
verwundert werden und das natürlich mit
sehr viel Leid verbunden ist und das
sehen wir natürlich jetzt
wir haben hier noch einige Fragen aus
der Community ich werfe da mal kurz
einen Blick drauf Jan soll fragt die
ersten Verteidigungslinien der Russen
wurden ja noch nicht erreicht das sind
unter anderem die Bilder die wir gerade
in den Beitrag gesehen haben mit welchen
Schwierigkeiten für die ukrainische
Armee rechnen Sie wenn wir vielleicht
noch mal ganz konkret auf diese
befestigungsanleitung gucken was ist da
schwierig
ja die Herausforderung ist und das muss
man eben verstehen dass hier die Ukraine
den sogenannten Kampf der verbundenen
Waffen anwenden müssen das heißt der
kampfpanz alleine der Leopard alleine
ist nicht die Wunderwaffe es müssen hier
verschiedene Systeme zum Zusammenwirken
gebracht werden wenn wir uns jetzt diese
russischen Verteidigungsstellungen
ansehen dann ist es zum Beispiel die
erste Herausforderung für die angreife
in Ukraine durch Minenräumen Fahrzeuge
eine minengasse im Vorfeld der
hauptverteidigungsstellungen räumen zu
können durch diese minengasse und da
muss man leider sehr eng auch
beieinander fahren können dann die
Leopard oder Schützenpanzer vorstoßen
und ein brückenlegepanzer kann dann z.B
einen Panzergraben eine Brücke legen
eine schnellbrücke und dann drüber zu
fahren dann reicht es vielleicht ein
anderes Fahrzeug mit zu haben wie z.B
einen Bergepanzer von die Prüfung oder
wie sind der dann Drachenzähne zur Seite
schiebt wenn Sie den Hindernis
darstellen um weiter Vorfahren zu können
und man muss es aber parallel das ganze
begleiten durch den Einsatz von
atillerie die Nebel schießt und zum
Beispiel panzerverlängerung Waffen der
russischen Seite des fahren zu
verhindern man muss es begleiten doch
mitfahren damit eben der gegnerische
Kampfhubschrauber Computer russische
kammauf 52 zum Beispiel nicht zum
Einsatz kommen kann und man muss das
auch noch begleiten für so viele Dinge
die wir vielleicht gar nicht zum Radar
haben wie zum Beispiel auch den
elektromagnetischen Bereich wo man
versucht durch Störung des Gegners
seines Funkverkehr Alarm zu Längen damit
dass er ja keine Reserve reinholen kann
und diese Reserven aus der Tiefe die
muss man zum Beispiel mit
fernverlegbaren auch tatsächlich
versuchen zu behindern also es gibt eine
Vielzahl von Komponenten denn das
Militär ist im Prinzip wie eine Uhr sie
kann nur exakt dann die Zeit anzeigen
wenn all diese kleinen Segmente da das
Sekunde Zeiger der Minutenzeiger und all
diese Rädchen Zusammenwirken gebracht
und das ist die Herausforderung ist
heute
und hier ist noch ein Zuschauer der noch
mal auf das guckt was sie gerade
angesprochen haben was sie gerade
angesprochen haben nämlich darauf wie
unglaublich lange diese Front ist ähm
hier fragt top Senf auf Youtube anhören
oberstreise nach hoffe die Ukraine
vernachlässigen nicht ihre anderen
Frontabschnitte wären die ihre Angriffe
hat die Ukraine genug Soldaten für alle
Fronten
da muss man also auch verstehen dass in
der sogenannten Vorbereitungsphase der
Offensive die Ukraine versucht hat die
Frauen sogar noch zu verlängern für die
russische Seite zum Beispiel durch diese
gezielten Angriffe im Raum Belgorod da
hat man also versucht russische Kräfte
dort in diesen Raum entsprechend
verlegen zu lassen und zu binden damit
die Front noch länger ist und damit es
um die Russen noch weniger Reserven zum
Einsatz haben wir sehen ja das ist die
Ukraine es geschafft hat tatsächlich
über die letzten Monate stabil entlang
der gesamten Front durchgehende
Verteidigungsstellungen auch anzulegen
und die Russen ist nicht geschafft haben
auch während der Winterzeit denken wir
zum Beispiel den Jena hier selbst in die
Offensive zu gehen und einen operativen
Durchbruch zu ziehen im Gegenteil man
hat sich dann also festgelegt auf diese
Stellungen die man bezogen hat ich denke
dass z.B doch die Sprengung des Darms
und so sieht es ja aus im Süden die
Russen ist geschafft dann tatsächlich
den Südraum für die Einsatzführung
vorerst unbrauchbar zu machen dann darf
er nicht vergessen ein Teil der Front
ist auch der Fluss nebenra und es macht
natürlich für die Russen leicht an der
sogenannten südlichen Flanke Kräfte
abzuziehen die man jetzt im Norden
einsetzen kann ich denke die Ukraine hat
in den letzten Monaten gezeigt dass sie
schon sehr in der Lage ist dachte die
Front und die auch alle möglichen
bestehenden Lücken zu überwachen aber
natürlich man versucht jetzt natürlich
gleich zusammen zu ziehen und
anzugreifen und es wäre theoretisch
denkbar dass er die Russen an einer
anderen Stelle angreifen es gibt es
einige Indizien z.B für Kämpfe in
kubianer gefunden aber gut aber ich
denke dass die Jugendliche Seite das in
der operativen einsatzführungen mit
berücksichtigt hat und auch dort lokale
Kräfte bereitgestellt hat
und zum Schluss habe ich noch eine Frage
für Sie die so ein bisschen in die
Zukunft guckt und hier fragt Kimmy Maro
auf Youtube wie lange wird die Offensive
andauern und was ist ihre Einschätzung
was eventuell bis September passieren
könnte
ist jetzt natürlich unter einem enormen
Erfolgsdruck sie dürfen nicht vergessen
in Kürze ist auch das
autoverteilungsminister Treffen in
Vilnius dort möchte man wenn geht dann
natürlich schon Ergebnisse zeigen um
sich auch da Unterstützung zu versichern
weil sie dann Auto starten für die
weitere Offensive Einsatzführung die
Herausforderung besteht jetzt darin was
in diesem Kräfte Ringen von beiden
Seiten die Oberhand zu behalten und
möglichst dann günstiger Stelle nicht
komplett breit und der gesamten
Verteidigungslinie sondern günstiger
Stelle einen Durchbruch zu ziehen die
man dann mehreren kann mit zusätzlichen
Kräften und dann rasch vorzustoßen und
damit diese strategische Situation zu
schaffen zum Beispiel der Teilung der
russischen Kräfte in der Nord und in den
Südbereich und das kann natürlich ja
dauern das kann der Wochen dauern das
kann auch durch Pausen unterbrochen
werden das kann sich möglicherweise
einstellen und dann wieder fortsetzen
das ist das was wir auch aus dem
vergangenen Kriegen erkennen ich
vergleiche in diesen Krieg auch immer
wieder mit dem Ersten Weltkrieg
natürlich waren die Rahmenbedingungen
damals anders aber manche Stimmungsbild
das sind sehr ähnlich wie zum Beispiel
haben 1914
Sieg 1915 dann wäre nüchterung und das
verstehen dass man nicht getan hat oder
1916 das Jahr der unterschiedlichen
offensiven die dann auch nicht das
Ergebnis gebracht haben momentan ist es
das Ziel der Ukraine zu zeigen dass man
in die Offensive kann das tut sie jetzt
gerade und man muss jetzt Geduld haben
und warten was die Ergebnisse in der
nächsten Wochen möglicherweise Monaten
auch tatsächlich sind
Herr Reisner vielen vielen Dank dass Sie
meine Fragen und die Fragen unserer
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen so
ausgiebig beantwortet haben
herzlichen
ja und ich denke wir werden hier
wahrscheinlich noch öfter über die
Offensive ihren Verlauf und ihren
Ausgang sprechen und ich habe hier
gerade noch mal in den Chat geguckt und
sehe einen ganz nettes Lob an uns hier
schreibt Felix Copter möchte nur mal
anmerken dass diese Livestreams Klasse
sind so sieht die Zukunft von
newsformaten aus dafür bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich und sag natürlich auch
dass solche newsformate ohne euch gar
nicht möglich werden danke für eure
konstruktiven Fragen und Kommentare und
bis zum nächsten Mal